hi guys I'm Gregory I'm John
Tony Gill trees on Instagram social
media manager of bloom house and the
real reject as well as reason for Jerry
on Twitter and Instagram guys guys
Marvel fisting of the iron this is iron
fisting yeah cappella for iron 59 and we
should I go it up to a seminal company
coke irony visting we got an official
full-length trailer guide will talk to
you this do this marble other music I'm
Danny ran in a way a long time oh here
I'm Jenny ran second whoa okay but I
left here ten years old and a jet my
parents
I became the lone survivor I'm Mark
Wahlberg a near and thanks to the dead
why do wait at this long issue how the
hell did it learn martial arts
wedgie drain come on
[Music]
my father instilled in me a love and
respect to this company that has never
paid this is my home and is my company
this city is no place for daddy give it
up no pyramid will never happen to you
why are you really stuck here bad people
on the inside they should despise them
we need someone with special skills are
your bosses where I can train him
everywhere life
[Music]
the changes come on here we go one Oh
become what you were meant to be
Wow oh cool this that's cool that's cool
okay start off with some positives here
sexy lead actor sexy lead actor like his
curls like like their I'm a man I'm a
man of curly hair and like curls I'm
keeping in mind that the only trailer
for a show for any of these Marvel shows
that I truly really like was strongly
gravitated towards with the daredevil
trailers we've got Jessica Jones and
Luke Cage I didn't really care for the
trailers I ended up loving the shows
iron fist I don't really love this
trailer to be honest I don't it seems
kind of like a cheesy CW show granted
that works for the DC shows and all that
but it's hard to really grasp like with
just the three different trailers we got
for this it's like very different in
tone and you don't really get a good
glimpse of what the actions really gonna
look like yeah because I was hoping like
the one saving grace yeah there could be
like some really neat choreographed
action because there that was so well
known for that and I use a martial
artist too it hinted at that you know
it's only two minutes reading out time
exceed like some really cool action
scene is right now I mean it just seems
to be a little bit more on the seems a
little cheesy to me
yeah when you're saying about like how
that CW think it did remind me of like
the whole era of a like show how it like
scene for daredevil we got a lot of
martial arts but Jessica Jones and Luke
Cage we don't really get a lot of that
because they have like powers and really
need to use too much martial arts I feel
those two store very story base but this
one's anywhere I will show a lot but for
air devil like the best like a crafting
we really didn't get any of that in the
trailers and stuff so I feel like this
could have something that's just like
have some hidden [ __ ] bad-ass spice
things that go on as good as like its
management like that was like kind of
this is necessarily a choreographed
by seeing especially because where he
learned his martial arts I don't know
how about the comic except of course
they make it seem like he's really a
martial artist okay we're gonna get a
little bit mystical because we are going
to go you know to the angel MIDI where
he trained Internet and he's gonna have
at least something of a superpower and
we might get some martial arts like
there was that one thing that looked
like it was kind of Crouching Tiger Lee
Weyer getting with you know it looks
like that could be distinct about this
show but yeah I'm kind of with you it's
like I'm interested because I know I'm
interested in these show usually and the
trailer is like the coolest stuff in
this trailer almost gets me there I'm
not going to not watch the show I'm
going to binge watch all the episodes
that come out like within the week they
come out for sure I'm going to watch the
whole thing the thing is I'm not really
getting a sense with the marketing of
what its distinct tonin yes if you go
through the show like first off I think
it's okay to like make this argument
because they're kind of doing what they
deal with Captain America the first
movie by calling Captain America the
First Avenger and they're really
promoting this is a final defender yeah
they're really trying to build a supper
the defenders now and I hope there's not
too much of trying to get that in there
and just focusing on this yeah because
daredevil had a very specific vigilante
in the criminal underworld story Jessica
Jones was a private investigation
mystery-solving you know noir stunn know
our style Luke Cage had the black
exploitation gang survive here I'm
seeing a lot of elements borrowed from
like there's you get that Iron Man flare
there you even get Doctor Strange flare
in there and you get even some Batman
Begins when I was like humbler company
but I'm not really getting a sense of
what's going to make this one unique and
really stand out
yeah Wyatt why should I be excited this
guy's the last yes and then the plot
here doesn't really it seems like from
what I know from the comics seems rather
faithful to the source material at the
same time though I don't really see it
it's something unique that's really
hooking me here other than the fact that
this is the final defender and that's
why I'm going to tune it if I learn that
to me has it looked like super unique
from the trailer I feel like the
organization that they're trying to
bring into this is probably going to be
what does is it's going to be like the
big enemy in the defenders because I'm
not sure exactly who was like with axes
and stuff but I watched a couple
breakdowns one and they talked about
like the big hand being a big
organization in this and I think that's
what they're going to try to bring into
this show is like this is the new threat
that will actually probably bring
everybody together this will be their
Luna they just probably want to involve
him but I don't feel like there's going
to be too much I guess resolved like how
it seems like in daredevil or Jessica
Jones or even Luke Cage worth they got
the enemies resolved yeah at the end
this one I feel like it's going to lead
into the defenders they do want to play
it as the last defender so like they
could make the show but it is hard
because it's like just how you said
Captain America whether it's like we got
to throw that in so we can bring the
defenders into it I don't think they
really need to keep pre-marketing the
defenders though I don't were all gonna
show it we're going to show a wide area
coming so I kind of how I felt with the
movies and phase one where it's like
they did Iron Man it was great they had
a plan for the Avengers down the road
then they started like let's just put
them a little bit more this is go
Captain America the First Avenger oh
you're all we're at it yeah right here
it's like alright we had gear no that
was great and then you get Jessica chubs
then you get daredevil season 2 just
like if we get Iron Man you at one point
is and then we have Liu became and then
now you have this and they're like the
pressure when exactly like this yeah and
then they make bran and Punisher so he's
supposed to get his on series to true
that true that would be that's going to
be a I hope that when you know the
inevitable Jon Bernthal Punisher Steven
comes out they sent them after like a
really supernatural character you know
like a like a witch of some kind
yeah maybe with the Joker and some other
people you're really cool Maina Suicide
Squad again yes I'm not going to ever
weld and I thought it would work I was
like I didn't actively squad work I
don't know I heard that regardless of my
concerns about the marketing and the
lack of enthusiasm from the trailer it I
will definitely be watching this show
regardless with an open mind because
like I said Jessica Jones and
case shows didn't really hook me this
trailer doesn't really hook me all that
much but I'm still gonna watch the whole
[ __ ] thing and I'm probably going to
end up really liking it so yeah the
track record doesn't do this but this
will go wrong yeah I believe it's gonna
be going man all right guys you can
subscribe to the real rejects countyís
trees on instagram because he works for
bloom house they run the social media of
the real rejects as well as recent Jerry
on Twitter and Instagram
shout out to Kristian harloff ah the
schmoes know in Collider video Christian
I went through the bathroom the other
day at Collider studios and Christian
was peeing tiny penis
tiny tiny penis to shout out the
Kristian harloff